but so anyway all right you know we just
comedy this and that you know I'm still
mad and then Orin meets Natasha Leggero
you know and you guys live together no
no we just dated I didn't live together
no and then we were in love yeah for
sure
yeah deeply yeah he was no man would
ever go through all of that then beat
you up for three weeks build it up yeah
yeah so you know seen Natasha it's cool
and then I met I bring Ron Peterson to
the Comedy Store yeah
she's performing in the belly room my
irelia tiger by the room and he guys
says that girl's hot like oh yeah she's
dating my friend Ari so I don't care I
don't know yeah that's fine
so I go down to the order to set he
stayed up there he got her number right
yeah she then we leave I don't know
anything about it at that point but now
but apparently he's now moving love
letters love letters flowers yeah taking
her to like the Opera Oh fancy right
towards the right as we were breaking up
awry opera that was like I think one of
their first dates or something how did
you find out about it about what I am I
had her password for her email and i was
reading the [ __ ] boat and you went
crazy I mean I was like what do I do
here I was thought of like just blocking
his email so that she wouldn't know so
that there would be like I guess he's
not even willing me anymore right but
then I was like no let her make the
right decision
that's mistake where were you at in your
career at this point Siri okay he wasn't
I just need like I wasn't I was at even
a paid regular think I'm I don't know if
I was I might have been go up in the
belly room so here's this guy who's
wooing her with the Opera and everything
all these TVs that money yeah yeah and
right around then too I started noticing
one time I was at Natasha she was in a
studio apartment and I know it's this
other guy I was flirting with her I
noticed because she I was on her
computer it was kind of a room like this
but like say a bed over there no it's
computer over here she took a phone call
and then went to the
kitchen and I was like that's weird wait
what the word thinking that and then I'd
look to see who that was was like okay
it's this guy flirting with you when I
start when I decide like I think it's
time for me to be jealous I found stuff
yeah I was like I was right to be
jealous right but before that I was like
no I trust her but you were also in love
I think Oh with her yeah sure sure sure
so he's now suffering yeah I'm suffering
you were suffering
yeah and I knew and I knew he was
sending her flowers cuz he said
something one of his emails like my
delivery gut it was it was late today
sorry it'll be there tomorrow for the
flowers and I went over to a place and I
saw the flowers and I was like what are
they and she was like she realized that
I knew yeah and she was like they gonna
hit me yeah Jesus and so then what I
said that so then I was you know crying
in the bathtub oh yeah man and Bobby
called me and Bobby called me and was
like hey what happened I saw them I was
driving down sunset around Hollywood I
saw them going into the Opera yeah and I
was like what and you're like hey I saw
them go to the Opera and I don't know
what it is I just want to know and I
pieced the other pieces that you that
you were calling me because Ron was I
hey find out if they're still dating her
if they fully broke up oh yeah I did not
know this part of the story piece it
together you're telling me that you were
conspiring that she was caught in the
middle to be obviously this and okay
let's just get this straight
yeah there are two sides to every story
I sorta [ __ ] okay do what I have to
say first and then you chime in all
right
whether that be true or not whether that
be true or not it could be true right
sure
no let's just it's true yeah okay I'm
sorry
I'm sorry all right all right I will
throw that out there all right yeah I
like the thing is is that the thing that
made you angry
didn't happen which is you thought that
I had set them up right well I found out
that you that he was showing you the
love letters he was setting all the time
I think you told me that yeah and then
and then it was like look I know what to
do yeah yeah I did not heartbroken
prized it was a surprise to me but there
was shocking to me the day were you know
seeing each other because I felt
responsible
I'm trying to think now with no with no
emotion behind it now if okay let's put
it on here hmm
if I'm trying to think who I don't know
Fahim start like hook it up with you
when he was like how are you I'm like
she's flirting I'm trying to think now
unemotionally evolved if I'd be like oh
no don't you can't do that that's
Bobby's girlfriend or if I'd be like
what if we had already hooked up would
you tell Bobby okay yeah I'll tell you
like give me the good comparison so I'll
gonna tell you that why it's different
the difference is this is is that I'm
new on mad so several years in yeah also
it's still in mad terms that's been new
okay you're not a regular yet you're
still featuring or whatever okay and
here's a guy who he even get to show he
didn't audition what happened was Martin
Short well they did any more white
people no but Martin Short found him in
Canada alright anime whoreson Lee came
down with Ron oh that's why he went
right back to Canada right so he was he
had Canadian heat on him Yeah right and
these people that I'm I so you know I'm
in a situation now words I want Ron to
like me I love you you know but I'm in a
situation okay you always back then two
of always worried about everyone like
yes yeah I know now people hate me
that's fine yeah okay I have accepted
their that's fine that's what the world
is one time I asked Bobby we were in a
car together and we're talking about
somebody who didn't like him and I was
like and this Werner still like really
good friend before any of this I was
like how come so many people hate you
like what am I like a lot I didn't even
know I was just like questioning like
what why yeah I don't know I mean like
five people that I held yeah yeah I know
and it's not like they all hate you from
the same my party that you got drunk
ever hatreds I was also hated in San
Diego when I started I know it's like I
don't nothin like maybe it's your voice
or something man is something people
hate I'm gonna tell you what I'm gonna
tell you why
yeah okay I am gonna tell you why all
right and the reason why I don't have a
lot of enemies now yeah is is that when
I started yeah it's all I had comedy
yeah it's all I had you nothing gets in
the way right all right I was very
opportunistic yeah yeah yeah I cut
through corners I'm sorry it's fine yeah
all right and I did everything I could
and yes I created some enemies and many
in many situations
I was unlikable I admit that I was young
all right yeah I'm 45 now in my 20 years
at work and I regret it Africa I regret
it yeah anyway sorry anyway no I like
this yeah I like the emotion so here's
the thing yeah so ah Bobby called me for
Intel for him and I was like first I was
like and then when I realized I think
you told me to break into his office to
gets things yeah I was like going to his
office and see see what he was she's
been writing him yeah they didn't have
back then at hotmail she a hotmail
account yeah you could either set it to
like save your sent messages or not an
email now I just say it so I was like I
couldn't see what she was sending him
yeah so I was like hey go in there and
find out and you're like I don't know
and then you do it this is what you said
to me what you said if you don't do it
yeah that means that you set them up oh
right which was which was so absurd to
me that his computer is at Fox we're on
a television show boy so I have a
[ __ ] break into oh this Canadian
guy's office somehow find his code no
he's already logged in
[Laughter]
probably would have done it now yeah but
then it was just it was and I that night
so then Friday comes around and I say
you totally hit me I was like oh you
were calling for Intel you weren't
calling to say hey I saw somebody walk
driving down the street you didn't drive
down the street and happen to see
Natasha and Ron going into an opera
right and then I saw you at the store
yeah and I was like hey do it like it
hit me now where you were on this yeah
I'm pretty mad and you're like and then
the way he was smiling I couldn't think
one thing I just say one thing
get the [ __ ] away from me Omid I did
that and you're like the reason I was
like I don't think you hit him like how
much is hurting me like they're just
they want that I'm like dude get the
[ __ ] away I'm gonna hit you and then you
kept doing it and I just punched you and
you fail so you didn't even give me the
satisfaction of fighting back but you
kicked me when I was down there yeah
while you were down take a man while
he's down yeah because you can't punch a
man while he's down that's weird can I
say something yeah question Bobby has
told this story yeah probably a good 12
times over the course of 90 episodes on
this podcast Wow and every time it's
always made me feel like God Ari is a
[ __ ] dick like for three weeks in a
row this is the first time where I
completely see it your way
you're a [ __ ] snake anytime you hear
a story and you're like wow that's
[ __ ] crazy you gotta stop it go that
is crazy
yeah I probably don't have all the
details because that's not normal what
I'm hearing right it always sounded
unprovoked Ari punch someone for no
reason he seems alright he's weird
alright I'm gonna defend myself no
that's not them with the defense all
right I was known to help a lot of young
guys I believe yeah
I've I felt like you know always helped
me but I've helped him a lot
we were friends we've had these
experiences right that's the reason why
I'm done with John Caporal I'll say it
on the fungal day yeah you're gonna take
money tax no because I felt like I
helped that kid Yeah right and there was
no respect you know coming from hit his
end and that's where the riot ambassador
so you know when you kick me in the face
I'm in body to who should say yeah
afterwards they like Bobby you're up and
then I guess we got separated and then
he was up and he's like Walker than my
spot so he went and did his spot and his
face started swelling up wall he was on
stage yeah yeah so yeah scratchin is
easy by the way he was the cover booth
guy he was happening right in front like
Bobby's talking to Steve I want to check
in I saw Bobby was like get the [ __ ]
away from me
yeah and then Steve was there and it
took him probably about a good two three
minutes now 45 seconds but that was
enough for a punch down kick 45 seconds
long how long do me ask you this I think
how long how long would it take you if
you wanted to going mid speed from the
cover booth to where I was if it was two
of my if it was two people I know okay
Kim there might be a second like wait
what the [ __ ] is have what's happening
like to grasp it yeah and then we rose
like I gotta I gotta do something 10
seconds 20 seconds it with the huh what
are you gonna run out come around 20
seconds tops tops right 45 45 seconds so
he 30 seconds of up watching oh yeah
so that happened God if I went up and I
went to thank you the one that when the
when the leg sucks
stops like you kick a soccer ball you
let go screw the soccer ball not like
like kicking a wall but like just like
yeah it felt great
yeah and then I went to the management
of the store
Freddie told me what he found out to his
like wait you could punch him trying to
like mentally [ __ ] with him but I
realized yeah yeah I went to the manager
of the store and I go I demand for him
to get banned bannd was like the worst
thing
and they said no I don't remember yeah
so week goes by
yeah and then oh but here's enough
here's the thing the the psychology
behind it you know the thing is is that
there's nothing the matter of a beat you
up
it punched me now there's been other
people that punched me but I also owe
you money you owed me $5,000 so a lot of
it has in it took me a long time to even
get him the money back yeah what you
just making that much in a week and I
eventually start borrowing money to pay
my rent
so that's where I think his resentment
was partly yeah a little bit money for
sure
yeah I felt justified it be like this
[ __ ] didn't pay back with money
I'm but also I'm the one that got him a
commercial agent for him to have money
but poppies the only kind of guy who
will bring that over your head everyone
else like let me help you and I never
think about it again
alright Bobby's like Buhl me alright
that's alright aqua you know it was an
aqua then right was it aqua yeah it was
Otto's origin about watching yeah yeah
yeah soon then the week later you come
up to his I want my money and you
strangled me in the hallway yeah I was
well because I remember because there
was blood I had I had I was like it was
like a two-finger yeah I was like this
that and then you were like you didn't
like I was like hey I want my money yeah
just this to fit and then you you were
like you started coming towards me yeah
I was like no I just started squeezing
yeah he was like yeah it was long like
coconut dug right into the skin and
start bleeding I went upstairs because
this is when I was dating Sarah yeah
right and she was upstairs doing some
sort of Adam I wanted to [ __ ] her to get
back at you I was like I'm not even into
it but I was like yeah I think I'll do
this they called you right after you
broke up I was like I know you still
care yeah this guy loved it
so now my still he had sex with seven
people there's no way I could pull her
it wasn't like
yeah you do it a month Aaliyah so now at
this point you know neck bleeding the
week before you beat me up now I hate
them and I'm scared like I literally
have like kind of a PTSD kind of a
situation where I'm like shocked by it
yeah
it's trubbish trauma and no one will
help me you know how you're young I was
young - and this is why now when I see
people like when they go crazy and it's
over like heartbreak I'm like you can't
judge them they're not thinking right
yeah they're young and I'm crazy yeah
but then here's what happened
so then the next week sorry auditions
for mind of Mencia yeah right yeah this
is before the Mencia rogen stuff
happened yeah and Mencia wasn't in the
auditioning room it was Robert Morten -
hired him because you like that's what
Robert told me that he would audition
for yeah I'm a casting director but like
they approved it yeah Robert Morten yeah
yeah but all I didn't know so I mean
Carlos Mencia didn't know
so when Carlos finds out the Orient
booked the job and in a sketch and we
were fighting he called you and said hey
bro I can't have you on my show what
they just said they brought the part he
didn't call me he didn't call you
he's the worst man he's you know he's
like oh yeah man they just wear out the
part it's not that good so he told me
that he had called you and said April
you can't beat up my friend and all that
stuff he acts like hey you guys stop
being it my friend and then later it was
like the part was written out now he's
he'll never uh so anyway but did you
think that I'm the one because I've
asked him to fire me yeah yeah yeah I
was yeah I wasn't okay I believe you
okay
why would I do that I didn't even know
about wait yeah I mean if you had
questions why would I do that
the answer is clearly this guy just
punched me two times can you please get
him fired why would I
how would I even know that you got hired
all that song I don't know Carlos go
ahead that guy got a job my show okay
can you get him not that I'm not saying
you did yeah yeah that's a that's a
that's a getaway didn't do it yeah all
right so then I was like Bobby got me
fired I was like well that's a line in
common
where it's like it's so hard to find
jobs you can't [ __ ] with someone's
income but with their job with the ride
of his career so Hawaii right so and I
was like what I have to punch it now the
rest is rageful this is like no no this
is the right thing to do yeah so I'm at
the parking lot at the Comedy Store
mm-hmm and I just hear running running
gonna do a Superman punch from behind
Davis I saw Bobby Bobby
running away hit me from the bit back
and then I felt number one defensive
movies okay I'm sick right now um that's
my defense move I wrestle in college no
no are you six foot three yeah I'm 5'4
you have a better bus you out waving by
50 pounds way too hard at that so then I
go to the outside of the room yeah so I
cover boo another cover but I go to the
office yeah you call the police yeah and
Steve run is is he yeah to his credit
pulls the [ __ ] cord out of the wall
damn so don't call the police
yeah and his excuse was it was a Friday
and he goes if Ari goes to prison he'll
stay there over the weekend and they
told me he was calling the police so
like I left my apartment I was like I
gotta get out of here cuz I'll come to
my apartment so I just left once it's
like open mic or something and just like
I guess they have to like 2:00 a.m. so
the police won't find me right did they
banned you then I think up for a month
or something after that they banned me
and then the other like you can't be
beating up Bobby three times two is okay
but three times yeah
I was banned enough when I was during my
husband I heard Freddie died Brenna's
easy calm he's afraid died yeah believe
it I lived down the street like right
next to the pink duck door and I walked
down there and I was me I remember
sitting on the curb like outside seeing
somebody hugging them and then just like
sitting there like crying and then
dombarris came by goes well I'm glad to
see you're respecting the ban I'm not
coming in the building well not because
of that but just because you know I
broke down there but and then it sort of
they like talk to Bob you'd work it out
and so as a fine let's talk yeah and
you're like I just I'm like fine okay
talk then and it's not what I wanted I
was like to do it yeah but he those just
he would also do this even after he got
back in I'd walk down the hallway and he
would just say [ __ ] like here's the
dumbest guy in the [ __ ] building I
know it would bother ya things that he
knew that would bother man you just you
can't even get a thought together you
can't even speak English do that you're
born here you're like he would say [ __ ]
to get me riled up and I would just be
like I can't even come here I hate this
guy it was like that for years holding
court to be like for people around you
know him and like fear that people talk
what are you doing listening Bobby's
lies you're lying about something that's
what you do you buy that was pretty good
psychological oh my god I hated the
props pretty good very good and then how
long was it years five years you years I
think four years could be for five years
forty five years of not talking to him
at all that's crazy
[Music]